[Music]
you also have I want to mention this a
line of pet accessories at petsmart yeah
and I was enjoying looking at these
today let's take a look at you have
absolutely that's a dog and horse head
for a dog then this next one is a dog in
a bandana I like that look and you have
a cat in a bandana oh no I'm sorry in a
cowboy hat that cat looks miserable that
cat does not look happy i canna lie but
cats like delighted to have that on
these are fine quality products I let's
list that we have a clip here from the
new show rock my RV let's take a look
bars the kitchen goes I had to pull back
on my dreams a little bit and it's
killing me after looking at this problem
Bodie and I came up with a plan talk to
Brett about the changes and how it just
wasn't gonna work you know the mechanics
and the physics about it he took it all
in stride was really good sport this
this is a great idea just not effective
what you've done is gonna be effective
and it's gonna be really effective
totally simplified it we're just gonna
take out that window right there big
changes all part of the design process
now I think it's time maybe that we just
drop kick this window right at I hate
that window yep it's got going right
about it I'm done with the chitchat it's
time to come who this window out
[Music]
that's all
no it's uh that one moment when the
window went come out I looked as
miserable as the cat one moment we've
been talking about this window I'm like
let's just take this thing out of here
we have mice cussing it for two days
right it's a big metal that's the method
to remove glass kids make sure you had